-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
President Biden has reportedly
met with
at least three Supreme Court
candidates in the hopes
that one of them will prove
worthy to join the elite group
of the most respected legal
minds in the country
and Brett Kavanaugh.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke yesterday
from the East Room
about the Ukraine crisis
and said,
"As Russia contemplates
its next move,
we have our next move
prepared as well."
Spoken like a man
on the fifth row of Wordle
with only two yellow squares.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, Wordle is hot.
Wordle is hot to the touch base.
[ Imitates sizzling ]
[ Laughter ]
Russian lawmakers
voted yesterday
to give President Vladimir Putin
the formal approval to use
military force in Ukraine.
Putin said, "The approval came
with approximately
117% of the vote."
Pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
Could've used Wordle
in that punch line.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry. It's hard
to follow a Wordle joke.
President Biden met yesterday
with the Ukrainian
Foreign Minister.
The meeting wasn't planned.
He just very quickly
decided to move here.
[ Laughter ]
"Any good restaurants?"
In a new episode
of a right-wing podcast,
former President Trump said that
Russian
President Vladimir Putin's
invasion into Ukraine was,
"Genius and wonderful,"
and I got to say,
it's a pretty brilliant way
to make Putin
second-guess himself.
[ Laughter ]
"Who likes plan?
Oh, boy. This is not good."
[ Laughter ]
"Genius? Ay, yi, yi."
You -- We fact-checked that,
right?
We fact-checked that Putin, when
he's upset, says "ay, yi, yi"?
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to be out here
looking like a -- Alright.
According to a new report
published in
"The New York Times" magazine,
an aide to former President
Trump described
a 2019 White House meeting
with Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas' wife, Ginni,
as being so crazy that Trump
"tried to reign it in."
Whoa, you know things are bad
when Trump is the one
trying to keep things on track.
That's like Bruce Willis
telling the director,
"I feel like this movie
has some plot holes."
[ Laughter ]
During a lunch
in Kentucky yesterday,
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
said that President Biden is a
"thoroughly decent human being."
Added McConnell,
"And if it wasn't for that,
we'd probably get along great."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a Florida attorney
was recently arrested
after she allegedly stripped
naked in a bar
when they refused to serve her
because she was too drunk.
And she must be
an amazing lawyer,
because she still talked them
into a scotch and soda.
And that was the monologue,
everybody!